INTERVIEWER 1: You recorded
your videos together, sort of
are partners.
ANDREA DESROSIERS: Yeah.
INTERVIEWER 1: Are
you excited, nervous?
ANDREA DESROSIERS:
You're excited.
I can tell.
He was all bouncy
when he came in.
INTERVIEWER 1: Really?
What was the hardest
part about the class?
Or maybe about
making the projects.
ANDREA DESROSIERS:
So I'll go first.
For me, it was a lot of
psychological barriers.
First of all, being on camera.
And I think you have
shared that as well.
And then just channeling the
rusty, disused, artistic part
of my brain, which really
only comes to the fore
when I'm under
extreme pressure and I
know I have 24 hours
to get something done.
But that's when I felt
the most creative.
It had to be a lot
of pressure though.
INTERVIEWER 1:
Nathan, how did it
feel doing the
second cut this time?
NATHAN HERNANDEZ: The second cut
I thought I had a better chance
to fix the little things and
work on putting the finishing
touches, I guess.
INTERVIEWER 1: Do you feel
different-- better, worse--
about being in
front of the camera?
Same?
NATHAN HERNANDEZ:
Probably the same.
INTERVIEWER 1:
NATHAN HERNANDEZ: I don't think
it got any worse, at the very
least.
INTERVIEWER 1: That's good.
INTERVIEWER 2: How are
you feeling right now?
INTERVIEWER 1:
Yeah, like you guys
are being super natural
right now, totally on camera.
NATHAN HERNANDEZ: I have my
nervous leg [LAUGHTER] shake.
INTERVIEWER 1:
But, I don't know.
I feel like a lot of people
were selling themselves short,
thinking that they were
not good on camera.
But you guys were on
camera the entire time
the class was going on.
And everyone's very compelling.
Everyone's very natural.
What piece of advice
would you give
to people who would be
interested in making
educational videos?
NATHAN HERNANDEZ:
I guess it would
be to try not to worry too
much about the actual part
where you're on camera
because it's painful,
but if you keep doing
it enough times,
eventually you'll get a
cut where you say something
all right.
INTERVIEWER 1: So this
class was super high-paced,
very condensed.
Do you think it would work
as a semester-long class?
Or do you prefer it as
sort of this [INAUDIBLE]?
ANDREA DESROSIERS:
Oh, I would love it
as a semester-long class, in
particular because learning
editing, more advanced editing
techniques, learning more about
animation, which I think
for an educational video is
really critical to convey
the ideas that you want to.
And I know that's one thing I
didn't really have time to do.
And that made me sad.
Oh well.
INTERVIEWER 1: How
about you, Nathan?
NATHAN HERNANDEZ: More
or less the same feeling.
I feel like there's things
that could be expanded on.
But I also do like the idea
that you just have three weeks,
and at the end you've
got something out
of it, which is also cool.